hello in this video I'll be talking
about all linked glycosylation so what
does glycosylation means
glycosylation is simply attachment of a
sugar residue to something and this
something is a protein so just like
depicted here
the box is stacked with the address tag
and that would be easier for the
delivery machinery to deliver it to its
proper location now
this tag could be different as well so
if we signify all in glycosylation as
this green tag as you can see the
location is different and the
Constituent that the tags made up of is
also different so these are differences
between ellington Kolding glycosylation
so let us look at Olin glycosylation to
appreciate this process and then we
talked about its biological relevance
and its function so Olin glycosylation
also takes place in the Colgate
Pereira's now unlike a link like
isolation Olin glycosylation takes place
in searing or tuning residues of a menu
acid and if you remember yelling
glycosylation takes part on as purging
residue so it it's a touched on as per a
gene not serine or threonine now there
could be multiple different structures
of these Oh link like isolation tag and
this tag varies from different protein
to protein but there are some classical
structures which are known as core 1 CO
2 or something very complicated like
pollyannas it'll back to some mine so
basically it contains of n acetyl
galactose amine and as it'll glucosamine
and sometimes galactose sometimes few
cause or the sugars could be different
now let's talk about what are the common
sugar residues in present in these
Olding glycosylation tags most common of
them is in linked Lucas M in asset
allocation mind galactose
fucose silac acid and many more so these
sugars that we talked about can we
further sulfate a torus it elated in
several residues and further modified
and each has a functional significance
to that
now for example the process of these
olden glycosylation
is catalyzed by in acetyl glucosamine
transference
which transfers the in acetyl
glucosamine group there and on once it
is transferred the further sugar
residues can be attached by several
other glycosyltransferase enzymes now
this is pretty important for example if
we talk about complement system which is
a defense response against the bacteria
so the mannose binding lectin determines
the Olding glycosylation on the
bacterial membrane and that is how the
the bacteria could be recognized by the
immune system and can be neutralized
so the lectin pipe pathways solely
depends upon map mannose binding lectin
and Olding glycosylation interaction so
it is super important in terms of
immunology now let's talk about very
common thing for example the red blood
cell has a antigen or B antigen on top
of its surface but do you know that H
antigen which is the base of it can be
either we modified into different
residues and based on that it could be a
antigen or it could be B antigen now not
only that the blood cells especially the
WBC's which need to go out in terms of
any kind of when the body is chale
challenged with kind of attack then it
need to roll slowly and in order to roll
slowly it needs to interact with the
endothelial cells the blood vessel cells
and the way it does is by P selecting
and integral
interaction and if we know that P
selecting is heavily glycosylated
actually this heavily glycosylation
helps the neutrophil to slow down and
squeeze itself out from the blood vessel
to reach the tissue space where the
attack has take place now if we talk
about mucins which are present in your
gut or present in your nasal epithelium
all these musings we can find Olding
glycosylated
it proteins and there are super
important in terms of combating with
bacteria or protecting your nasal
epithelium or intestinal epithelium so
we can see that old English oscillation
is important for so many biological
processes now not only that one of the
important structure in terms of tissue
is the extracellular matrix at several
accessory matrix components such as
fibrinogen fibronectin collagen etc are
heavily glycosylated and that in kind of
determines how much rigid the
extracellular matrix would be and that
could be very relevant in terms of the
biological property of the accessory
matrix so only in the legos relation is
super important so let's take a look
what we learned so far
so in ling glycosylation happens in a
sort of kind of sequential manner so you
have a core structure onto that it's
getting extended and you get capping now
here in case of Old English elation the
core structure is fairly simple on top
of that several glycosyl transferase
enzyme transferred specific residues and
you could have a wide variety of
variations in case of all ink like
isolation so only in glycosylation
variety is way more than the in Ling
like isolation variety and each of these
different kind of modifications can lead
to different biological functions so I
hope you enjoyed this introductory video
on these poling glycosylation if you
like this video give it a big thumbs up
and don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thing